victoria's choice uh victoria's choice
victoria's voice
foundation helps children and teens who
are dealing with opioid addiction
now saturday night at the west gate
they're having a benefit concert
featuring performances
from iconic boy band members including
jeff timmons from 98 degrees earlier i
spoke with jeff about the event
jeff timmons it's good to see you buddy
how have you been i've been great jc
good to see your face how are you
i can't complain i gotta tell you what
i'm so excited about the show tomorrow
night
victoria's voice is tomorrow night uh
let's talk
give everyone the lineup that's going
down tomorrow night uh look we've we've
got a great lineup some local talent
some international talent i mean we have
uh the soul of motown is gonna be on
there aj mclean from the backstreet boys
chris kirkpatrick from nsync
we've got chris blue i'm hosting it i
might sing you know who knows but with
all that talent
it makes me a little bit nervous but
it's going to be star-studded lineups
is this going to be your first
post-pandemic performance have you
performed since the pandemic
has started yes absolutely or or
appearance or like
official appearance it's going to be the
first one i mean i'm in i'm in illinois
doing something
uh you know shooting a little movie out
here so this is kind of my official
official first thing but first time
hosting something first time
singing in concert for a crowd without
masks and
i'm so i can't tell you how excited i am
and you know you know how it is
just going out and seeing the energy
from people right now it's pretty
amazing i think everybody sort of you
know
isn't taking for granted what they had
before so it's awesome to be in this
situation
victoria's voice music for life tomorrow
night at the west gate is going to be a
special night now jeff can you give us
an update on the band
98 degrees what do you guys have planned
for the rest of the year
you know we had 50 60 dates on the books
before pandemic those are still there
and we're coming out with a new single
uh pretty soon and some new material
remixes
there's just a ton of stuff that's going
on right now and all like i said you
know we're all thrilled just to be back
and working and
and you know still be around and still
have fans out there so
you know we count our blessings daily
for sure you got to catch a flight
because you're flying back home for this
event tomorrow night so i want to give
you some rapid fire questions okay
sure all right so first one your go-to
meal during the pandemic
um eggs
eggs hey i'm a high protein low carb
kind of guy so it's boring you know
eggs you know scrambled eggs every day
that works for me man all right so
what's what's the current show that
you're binge watching
um i i you know i revisited breaking bad
and uh you know i'm just in love with
that one i know it's a throwback but
love it
it was an amazing show um your last
purchase on amazon
i think the last thing that i purchased
were these speak these um
these curtains that are that sound proof
your your
windows in your house because my music's
been too loud my studio and my neighbors
complain
so it's soundproof curtains that's my
last person from amazon all right here's
the last one i want you to rank the
following first second third
the following three aj from the
backstreet boys
chris from nsync and jeff timmons from
98 degrees
go i can't answer those ques that
question like that i'll just say
they're all good in their their own
respects all of the guys have different
talents
and charisma and performance abilities
and all that stuff so
i can't pick a favorite but you know of
course i got to pick myself to be first
you know how that goes
exactly you're my number one always will
be
music for life for victoria's voice
foundation is happening tomorrow night
at westgate resorts
international theater starting at 7 pm a
star studded lineup
you can get your tickets at
ticketmaster.com
as we mentioned oh it is going to be
huge tomorrow night backstreet boys band
member aj mclean will also be performing
at tomorrow night's event and we will be
chatting with him about
the event what's new in his career and
something he's working on exclusively
for las vegas so make sure to tune in to
monday's show
for all of those details